what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
admittedly I've never been a huge fan of
the Transformers it's not really been my
thing like I know it was a show and I
know there's a huge culture behind it
but I'd never really had a reason to get
into it before and in all honesty like
anybody else I kind of get burned out on
Marvel and DC sometimes I just want to
like talk about something else and I was
trying to figure out a place to start
with transformers because they have a
really lengthy history now those people
who are really really knowledgeable
about transformers can probably give me
like a really good place to go to so
sure you know feel free to post a
comment and let me know what a really
good place to start is but as I was
going through the various stories and
looking what you know IDW had to offer I
came across all hail Megatron and the
good thing about this is that this kind
of picks up with like how the normal
person like me perceives the
Transformers the the subject calls and
the Autobots have been fighting each
other and apparently the Decepticons
basically won you know they defeated the
Autobots and now they set their sights
on earth so it's almost like picking up
with the Transformers Foom film but it
is cool because I got to tell you man
this story dude
this story all hail Megatron I never
realized how good transformers comics
were it is insane like it's it's
absolutely bonkers
and it's funny because like initially
this picks up with like the
Constructicons is right you know they
all just kind of show up and like it's
hilarious because they show up and
they're like hey guys like like we're
here as friends we're here to be nice
like we're here to you know give you
guys technology and stuff like that and
humanity is kind of excited about it
right I mean this is like huge robot
like huge sentient robots have appeared
on earth and you can kind of see it
going down like this right like Twitter
hashtags hashtag transformers but you
could see it happening you know and
people are like taking videos and stuff
and then like the the Constructicons
show just like no we're just messing
around and they start destroying
everything I mean it's not that's not
funny we shouldn't laugh yeah we
shouldn't laugh at the constructed cons
killing everyone but this is I mean it's
it's insane it's it's like an all-out
assault right like it's the
Constructicons then it's like the flight
transformers like Starscream and they
just kind of come rolling in and just
decimating everyone and it's awesome
Starscream you know from what I've seen
he's rapidly showing up to be like one
of my favorite characters because like
Starscream shows up onto the scene and
like from what I've been able to pick up
Starscream is like trying to take the
place of Megatron and it seems like all
the Transformers have like their own
personalities and what it is they're
trying to accomplish
some of them are just
like like ravage is just like diligent
to the transformers cause like yep I'm
alongside the Decepticons I am part of
this and I am never gonna become an
autobot whereas you have someone like
like Soundwave who's like yeah I'm
allied with the Decepticons so long as
their interests don't run contrary to my
own and it's kind of cool you know with
this with this whole thing but like like
humanity's just flee for their lives
right I mean this is hilarious people
are just like panicking running like
like oh it's the end times man and it's
pretty insane because from there like
Megatron jumps in and this is one of the
cool things I like because in my mind's
eye I look at Megatron is just like the
big bat is here Megatron is on the scene
and that's kind of what you expect right
I mean it's kind of what I expect I mean
we don't really get it but I would
expect like a full-page splash screen
like Megatron is here you know it's
funny because the interaction between
Megatron and Starscream right off the
bat is you're trying to usurp my
position I know you are but like you'll
never be me you'll try but you'll never
be me why because Megatron is often
imitated never duplicated and that's the
cool thing I love about it scared that's
why I love Megatron so much in this
story but it's funny because he like
talks down and kind of mocks
Starscream right I mean they're showing
up and they're they're like destroying
streets and cars and attacking people
and Megatron's idea is you think small
that's why you are small and he just
obliterates a city block just wipes out
a city block that's why it's so cool is
because you pick up with DJ like he's
just like you know one of the guys that
are out there and of course him along
with the air force it's just like
scrambling Jets and it is kind of cool
because it's like all right look like we
have to find a way to retaliate against
this now under normal circumstances we
wouldn't really expect humanity to have
a chance that gives the Transformers and
so they don't but if it's funny because
they they show up here as firing off
rockets that kind of a thing you know
and the cool thing is rumor with
Soundwave one of his abilities is
basically kind of like like disrupt you
know technology to a degree so in this
instance the Rockets that are firing
their missile guidance systems are just
kind of being disrupted by Soundwave and
they're just sort of going awry they
can't do anything and that kind of makes
sense where the transformers being as
advanced as they are we wouldn't expect
somebody to be able to show up and then
just like stab Megatron in the face with
a knife and then he wins like we
wouldn't expect something that primitive
and even with like jets and all the
technology that humanity has that's kind
of like the the foundation here that
like with all the great things humanity
has done all it takes is like a handful
of sentient robots and it all comes
crashing down now DJ for his worth is
just kind of like okay
you know if we can't take them down
using missiles because the guidance
systems don't work and bullets don't
penetrate their armor then like I'll do
the only thing I can do and like fly my
jet into Megatron and so it was a
suicide run the guy goes full kamikaze
and it doesn't work like when he flies
this jet directly and nothing happens
and it's just kind of like dude this is
designed to kind of be like this
scenario of like humanity has no hope
right like like things are kicking off
now like humanity can't really do
anything so it's kind of building up you
know this whole idea of just how capable
the Decepticons are now for here we pick
up with a guy a colonel wit wiki and
it's hilarious because he's talking to
this dude named Chad Wells and
apparently like Colonel when Twiggy
likes cars right and so you know Chad
Wells like hey man like your wife told
me that you like cars he's like yeah man
I dig cars and so Chad well there's like
I Drive a Toyota Prius and that's
adorable
you know and and with these responses
like yeah man my car is the 1968 Mustang
v8 fastback with a 390 cubic inch big
block and Chad Wells is just like ah
what's a v8 like it's hilarious because
I mean like I gotta be honest colonel
wit Wicky man he's got it going on like
my dream cars in 1971 Chevelle Super
Sport like that's what I want like I
just want like like like a muscle car
but it's kind of funny you know with
this whole thing because this exchange
is kind of designed to put us in this
mindset that when you look at Colonel
wit Wicky his place his residence what
he calls home its combat and the reason
for this is because he's initially
brought back in like he's basically hit
up by the US military Colonel we need
you to come in and notice how calm he is
like he doesn't really seem out of place
I mean it was a really out of place
before it was kind of a confidence of
like I'll do it because it makes my wife
happy but like this is where I belong
this is where I need to be and just sort
of races off now the funny thing about
this is like they hit him up but they're
like we have an emergency it's like what
kind of an emergency is it well gee I
don't know colonel wid Wicky sentient
machines have attacked New York and like
Humanity is just being totally decimated
like that kind of an emergency like and
the funny thing about this is that
indications are given that Humanity knew
about the transformers or at least the
CIA seemed to know about the
Transformers but no real informations
forthcoming it's one of those things
where it's you know beyond you know top
top secret we can't just tell some lowly
Colonel you know that kind of a thing
that you expected like the sort of
intelligence versus military exchange
and like a Hollywood film or something
like that but again this is all just
panic mode from the perspective of DJ
like he's running he's fleeing from
ravage he runs into a couple of people
they take refuge in
warehouse more or less and it's just
kind of were responding as best we can
now humanity is essentially setting up
response locations basically like here's
our base of operations I don't know if
it's called like like like triage from
what I understand triage is setting up a
place in order for people to like
receive medical treatment in a combat
setting I'm not familiar with military
terms so so forgive me if I kind of
botched that and screw it up in response
to this the Decepticons are kind of like
well I mean you know we can take this
different ways you know humanity's
basically set up like a huge you know
military campaign and they're gonna make
moves against us let's dispatch the
insecticons but the funny thing about
this is that Megatron's response is no
no we're not gonna do that what we're
gonna do is we're gonna dispatch frenzy
man let me tell you something man dude
did do frenzy is a one-man army like you
want to talk about crazy but you wanna
talk about absolutely not I love frenzy
here I don't know anything about it
don't know a frickin thing about frenzy
I've got no clue like what the deal what
the back story is about frenzy have no
idea like where he's coming from or what
he's about but damn it if is not awesome
because this dude shows up and cleans
house there's just like like the
military's like yeah man like we'll set
up here we'll begin our you know forward
operations we'll start taking back New
York City oh my bad we forgot about like
the insane Decepticon who's just going
to rip us to pieces and that's exactly
what happens now the other thing about
this is like the regular citizenry the
normal people the moms and dads and then
the average joes they're all just taking
off to like the Holland Tunnel get get
while the getting's good
now we jump to Colonel wit wiki he gets
he gets the notification right like hey
oh we got reports back about the whole
event we had a few casualties it's like
well okay well how many of them do we
lose everyone you know like in this
immediate location the US has virtually
no response and so what we end up doing
is finding out that like the
Constructicons has basically merged into
like Devastator again and so at this
point they start targeting the tunnels
and that's a panic of the military like
okay well now they're going for the
civilians but notice this this is a this
is a great military strategy by Megatron
on this surface it looks like they're
just like tearing things up what he's
doing here with New York is cutting it
off from the outside world
the tunnels get destroyed the bridges
get destroyed no one gets in or out and
it's a great strategy and so because
there's what we end up doing is picking
up with DJ and a handful of others in
the tunnel you know and then there's
like a train coming down the tunnel and
they're like Oh
it's a train the trains gonna rescue us
it is a train it is the pain train like
this is a like it like a trait of
Decepticon just manifests and just
starts just starts attacking people do
you know man
do I'm sorry from so excited people but
it is an exciting story but again it's
cool because humanity's trying it's
trying its best to respond to the
situation or at least in the immediate
you know with regards to like New York
and the surrounding areas
humanity's trying to respond the problem
with this is that the naval fleet was
supposed to be responding like it was
literally all hands on deck like that's
one of the cool things the president the
United States ordered that all military
personnel outside of the US be recalled
to the United States to defend its
borders and that's why this is
interesting because keep in mind
assuming this follows historical
accuracy of the United States
no foreign enemy has ever set foot on US
soil since the war of 1812 when the
British burned down the White House in
New York and the United States moved it
to Washington DC nothing like this has
happened since and so when this happens
it's like recall everyone get him back
here get him back here come on because
like machines are wrecking New York what
like the fleet there's there was a
simple radio broadcast over the fleet
and the indication is that it was being
absolutely eradicated over the course of
a handful of days the White House has
been totally destroyed you know Congress
is gone the president is gone the US
military is in shambles I mean is is
literally just like decimation on a
scale that like the US and the world
have never really seen before and so
that's why it's so intense that's why
it's so wild is because in the end you
end up having Megatron just kind of
surveys you know his his landscape
cervesas his you know headquarters more
or less and says this is where we will
operate from we will basically spread
outward we will take over this world
this will be on our land because Rubert
Cybertron is basically a dead world now
and so it's like we will take over all
this this is where we're going to reside
and so again it's almost like this this
war of attrition so to speak you know is
just overwhelming odds against the enemy
they can't possibly begin to comprehend
the technology they're facing off
against we jump back to Dj it's the
exact same thing DJ and them are hanging
out in the tunnels are hiding out people
are starting to dissent they're starting
to say look we don't really know if
you're an effective leader it's
desperation that's starting to kick in
no leaders actually been formed but when
it comes to these sort of panicky
situations in a time of desperation
people will believe what they want to
believe and they believe DJ is their
leader but where DJ says like I'm not
necess
running this show you know people begin
to kind of voice dissent they kind of
look at this and say look we need to get
out of here we have to go somewhere else
the city is in danger all the while not
realizing if they ascend from the from
the tunnels and they go out into the
streets of New York and they leave New
York and they get out into the rest of
the world it's no better everything's
just as bad Elmo almost everywhere else
and so what we end up you know kind of
ending this little bit a bit of a story
on is the decepticon returns yet again
and again that idea is to just take out
the tunnels to crush the subway stations
to kill as many people as humanly
possible in order to basically
exterminate the existing you know race
that's prevalent on on earth and then
replace them with Decepticons who
effectively run everything but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come this explain it make sure you guys
with the sub button to become part of
the robb cork you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]